it's no secret that the financial
industry and specifically Wall Street
has one of the most grueling work
schedules in the world as they often
work 80 to 100 hours per week it's quite
common to hear from Wall Street
professionals that they start work at
5:30 a.m. and don't finish till 7:30
p.m. or even later they literally just
work eat and sleep during the week but
why do they work so hard
[Music]
well starting off there are only two
real types of jobs in the financial
industry which are being a financial
analyst or a risk analyst virtually all
jobs in the financial sector will use
these same skills whether an investment
banker at Goldman Sachs or prestigious
hedge fund manager taking a closer look
at financial analysts there are two
basic types of financial analysts
buy-side analyst and sell-side analysts
by said analysts analyze various
investment opportunities and develop
several potential investment strategies
for hedge funds insurance companies
pension funds banks and so on and so
forth similarly sell-side analysts
analyze various holdings and recommend
which stocks and bonds and investments
that company should sell moving on risk
analysts look at each of these
recommendations as well as the company's
current holdings and evaluate the risk
of each investment and that's
essentially the entire financial
industry in a nutshell small groups of
financial and risk analysts will work
together to propose the best possible
investment strategies for an industry to
portfolio managers portfolio managers
will use the same skills as financial
and risk analyst along with their
experience to choose an investment
strategy for the industry they are in
charge of several of these portfolio
managers report the results to fund
managers who again use the same skills
to evaluate which industry is staying
and which to exit as you can see the
skills required remain constant
throughout the financial hierarchy and
the only difference between various
positions is responsibility and
experience so once they got the basic
skills down the job itself is pretty
easy to do and one of the main reasons
for such a heavy workload is because of
a simplicity of the job now don't get me
wrong here you need to be knowledgeable
in the appropriate skills to be
successful at the job but the job is not
necessarily an intellectually
challenging job and as a result is very
easy to replace in other sectors like
engineering unless you screw up really
bad you probably won't be let go in the
middle of a project it's usually not
worth their hassle to find another
qualified person to take over when you
are already well into a given project
and you might even be able to redeem
yourself by the end of the project but
in the finance industry they could
replace you the following day without
any hassle they don't have to do any
training for newcomers and these guys
don't need to have any background
knowledge to work done so far you know
to analyze a future investment so the
ease of being replaced often dries
financial professionals to be very
competitive and work long hours moving
on working long hours is often key to
survival of the entire company the vast
majority of financial companies are not
JP Morgan Chase or Wells Fargo with
millions of investors and investments
that taking one investment would be
negligible the vast majority of
financial companies are smaller
institutions are dependent on investor
capital to continue operation for
instance there are over 10,000 hedge
funds in the world but only 2,000
billionaires of course billionaires are
not the only people investing in hedge
funds but the point is the financial
industry is a buyers market
Wall Street is oversaturated with
investment options for potential
investors so logically investors are
only going to flock towards the funds
and companies with the highest returns
and least risk and in an industry where
you can't outsmart your competitors
given the rudimentary nature of finance
you have to outwork them as just a few
years of bad returns can lead to the
collapse of your entire firm and finally
the last major reason Wall Street works
so hard is the pay it's no wonder that
so many people are interested in working
in Wall Street as it is hands-down the
highest paying industry top hedge fund
managers make well into billions a year
beating up even the owners of the
biggest companies in the world even
starting out financial analysts make
well into six figures and can quite
reasonably work their way into seven
figures by just their 30s something else
to keep in mind is that each position in
the financial industry pays
exponentially more and the thing is the
people who enter a financial industry
aren't just looking to make a nice
income save up and retire these people
are highly motivated individuals
entering the financial industry looking
to become extremely wealthy
and the faster they can get promoted the
faster they can make that happen
as a result in the end the long hours
worked on Wall Street falls down to one
thing reputation as this is a key to
survive in such a competitive
environment are you the financial
analyst that always double triple checks
your work and never makes a mistake
are you the portfolio manager that
always delivers the best returns and are
you the manager of the best fund for the
last 20 years in the financial industry
reputation is a king as it is the only
feature that will help you stick out
from the crowd and reputation is not
something you get once in you're good
for life as long as you're in the
finance industry you have to continue
upholding that reputation furthermore as
a financial industry grows and more
hopefuls flooded the competitiveness
simply continues to grow pushing Wall
Street to work harder and harder if you
guys thought this video thoroughly
explained the motive for Wall Street to
work so hard then make sure drop a like
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then I'm Hari and I'll see you guys on
the next one